[Music]
this is branch rhythmic sports race I'm
sponsored by placing okay guys this is
it
semi-finals I'm really excited to see
who's going to race against me this
track is a special because it's a really
old school track I think it's gonna be a
race about keeping the car on track I've
been there I was a couple of months ago
especially last corner it's really
really interesting because you can roll
a lot of speeding it's a six field
corner
58 corner Tony Rohan and 40 miles 150
miles in a high downforce car like a gt3
car the culture driving it's a blind
corner you cannot keep the momentum to
but then if you make a mistake
there's no wolf that's just a lot of
desert so once you're in the gravel then
the gravel keeps you drags you out so to
be on the limit on this track will be
really interesting and then you have a
couple of corners we're really really
tight there's a lot of jump
tracks really bumpy so let's see who
wins right I'll keep it in second gear I
guess
nice and slow safe good luck yeah
you ready back there I'm ready how about
you I think I'm ready
should we keep this nice and polite uh
yeah yeah let's just smash into each
other as much as we can all right if if
you feel like you just freaked reach
back and give me a little slap there
okay right on the side of the face
[Music]
don't stiffen up the course yet we're
doing very well
this turn yeah this one's real nasty I
think I think I figured it out right at
the end you got to cut wide and then cut
in here I'm gonna here I didn't quite
work but whatever
mr. with me I see it you'll never let me
go I don't want to lose to Ricardo now
that was you that was your time don't
make any mistakes you catching up
final lap Lawrence needs to make a
mistake otherwise it takes a race watch
out behind you
are you coming up you're coming up
oh look at you you're right there
Oh
I thought your fishtailing a little bit
all right this is it no pressure no no
pressure at all final corner right and
he's close you know pick up
got this one so long so long and
grueling Ryan's going to die beam
oh dude you did the thing you did the
thing come on
ah that was cheeky dirty
kind of couldn't the inside like that Oh
give me a heart attack dude that was a
good one that was this right nice grace
very close oh I just realized what I am
and I was a risky move almost almost
almost
good job Lawrence thank you nice race
guys nice race
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys nice job four of you Ryan
respect you went too deep but this is
this is racing you know it takes just
tenth of a second or two tenths to make
a decision and I think you risk a lot
but that was last corner last lap so did
a good job on that call and then
Lawrence you made a really good race you
were leading by far and then you made a
mistake at the end and then Ryan got you
I'm sure so if you're in the position
you're behind yeah
let's say you're entering the corner
someone is taking the inside you entered
it with a certain speed and a certain
angle thinking that you could cut all
the way in and go all the way back out
so if suddenly you're you're cornering
line has changed you just have to tap
the brakes do you have to let off the
gas
have you have to bleed up speed what
does that entail for example last race
we were battling on the last last lap
and I knew where the guy will put the
car inside because because of the nature
of the corner so I block the inside
earlier than before okay so you guys
switch the entry speed for the eggs
this is where racing becomes really
smart sometimes because depends on the
next corner if it's a high speed corner
Lawrence I think you have done plenty of
training sure yes yes I have to write no
more letting off right now of course 20
minutes or so that's why I have done
maybe five hours per day okay so good
luck yes and see you see you in the
truck man hmm I'll try to lose with
dignity yeah that's all I can promise
[Music]